another present the scientific-technical
awards of Merit two brilliant actresses
are both nominated this year in the
category of Outstanding Supporting
Actress - welcome please Maggie Smith
and Maureen Stapleton
anyone who ever sees a movie let alone
works in one I was an enormous debt to
the technicians and inventors who are
constantly striving to improve the
medium every year the Academy presents
awards of Merit in recognition of
outstanding technical advances this
year's award winners have made it
possible for our work to be seen heard
and preserved a little better than
before and for that we are properly
grateful agree the first award of merit
for scientific achievement goes to
Eastman Kodak Company for the research
and development of a duplicating color
film for motion pictures here to accept
the award is the vice-president in
charge of the motion picture division
Kenneth and Mason
Thank You Maggie and thank you Maureen
on behalf of all my colleagues at Kodak
particularly those at Kodak Park I
accept this award with great pleasure
thank you very much
for the continuing research and
development of the Niagara magnetic
sound recorder for motion pictures the
Academy Award of Merit goes to Stefan
Kadal ski
merci beaucoup to the Academy and merci
beaucoup to my American partner northern
rider and his staff for contribution of
the use of Niagara recorders into motion
pictures I will remember this corner all
my life thank you
and the Academy gives an award of merit
to Robert god shock of Panavision
incorporated for the concept design and
continuing development of the panaflex
motion picture camera system robert god
all motion pictures nominated for
outstanding achievement in
cinematography both last year and this
year were photographed with a panaflex
camera we are proud of that thank you
Panavision design engineers technetium
al mare Jack barber george kramer oliver
conway and thank you steve ross chairman
of warner communication for your trust
in us and thank you howard w catch for
the Oscar for Panavision and its design
staff and of course for this one too
thank you